with the coronavirus here in the united
states clearly spreading who knows how
long it's actually been here there will
be an impact on the sports world sooner
or later and probably much much sooner
the nfl told me on sunday that it's
closely monitoring developments and has
been in contact with the world health
organization cdc nfl pa medical experts
and
uh those at the duke infection control
outreach network program for infection
prevention that is one hell of a
mouthful but um they're going to
continue to look at it throughout the
offseason here's the thing the draft is
51 days away i don't know what's going
to happen with this nobody knows what's
going to happen with this and i have not
even the the the shred of qualification
to wonder what may happen all i know is
there are a bunch of different ways it
can go and it can go in a way that makes
no one want to go to las vegas for the
draft no one and it could go in a way
more immediately chris we're supposed to
go to florida for the league meetings in
three weeks and five days yeah 26 days
away math may not be correct they may
not have that there's no need to have
that they could do it all by by facetime
if they want to so
uh you know these are decisions and if i
was going to have to be ready to make
quickly and we mentioned it today
because the nba according to espn.com
and sent out a memo to teams advising
fist bumps instead of high fives don't
take items from fans that you sign uh
you know pens and balls and and jerseys
that the fans have touched
nothing about possibly canceling games
or playing games without a crowd there
but uh you know the i think everything's
on the table because every potential
permutation and option is available for
this thing as we try to figure out what
it is how it's going to spread and how
long it's going to last yeah it's
concerning it is i mean i'm just hoping
it doesn't trickle into our everyday
life right now more than anything too
it's scary it's scary to me a guy with
no spleen i mean i know if i got it i'm
gonna be you know susceptible to the the
the harsher side of that so uh you know
and you listen to any expert out there
right now and they seem to think that
the spread is inevitable we just hope it
doesn't overtake us and yes i i would
hope that all these sports leagues and
you know to do the right things as far
as
avoiding unnecessary travel when it
doesn't need to be done and doing all
that i think can go a long way to you
know
helping this thing be contained and not
let it spread uh but but really crazy
and certainly something i got my eye on
for sure well and look some of these
steps are going to take a major bite out
of the economy we saw what happened to
the stock market last week chris it
rebounded somewhat on monday but you
know if if
if all of a sudden people just stop
going to sporting events that's a
problem even if the tickets are already
paid for nobody's there to buy any of
the stuff that's a problem they're
talking about possibly playing the ncaa
men's tournament game without a games
many games without fans in the stands if
it comes to it so you know look i think
it's important to plan for every
alternative but i also think that at a
certain level and i've seen how
different nations have handled this and
how different cultures will handle it i
we're kind of a nation that was founded
on the taking of risk i mean we started
a revolution against the king of england
and we have people who ride motorcycles
without helmets and jump out of
airplanes and climb rock walls and just
do guys that don't wash their hands when
they leave the bathroom i see it all the
time exactly so we have
renegades renegades i would call them
other words but yeah i i think that but
and i and thank you for not doing it i
just think that we need to wait and see
what happens it could be the thing
spreads and it could be that people just
continue to go about their daily lives
and accept the fact the incremental risk
that they're going to get it and uh and
and you know now for people in the
higher risk categories there needs to be
a greater degree of vigilance but i
think for the average person the average
american citizen i i really don't see
people consciously disrupting their
routine and denying themselves the
things they want to do because i think
part of our our defect as a society and
a culture is ah that's not gonna happen
to me yeah even if it does sure yeah
well it's a little bit of our american
way i mean confidence stupidity whatever
you want to say there you know i i mean
yeah we we do we seem to kind of just
continue to truck along and you know we
let the experts and the people who you
know seem to know most about the subject
kind of handled the situation and let's
let's hope we all continue to take their
advice listen to what they say you know
and hey you know me i'm a big fist
bumper because of the germs anyways
that's what i do so let's office bump
out there you know i don't want to
really shake any man's hand i don't know
where that hand's been i'd rather just
fist bump all the time
i wonder yeah it may have been holding a
trash can while the guy threw up into it
for example i wonder how different last
week would have been at the scouting
combine
if the news cycle had lined up you know
because it was like a week later
right if at all if it had just been a
week yeah either way
would we have been fist bumping would
there have been no handshaking would
people have been more leery and more
cautious and think about a sports team
if one guy gets it everybody's getting
it right how many times through the
course of a year do we remember that the
patriots this year they had 15 guys on
the injury report with the flu yeah well
if it gets into a locker room somebody
took two planes right the sick guy it
was the patriots he was the patriots
right yeah well it gets into a locker
room you're screwed i mean as you know i
mean that's just not exactly the most
sanitary place in the world you know you
got 53 men touching a lot of things
sweat touching they're naked whatever
else there's a whole lot of damn germs
in the locker room so you'd be screwed
if that got into a locker room it's
gonna spread like wildfire uh i just
hope that we can continue to contain
this and this doesn't become a huge
issue where you know it ruins our
country or really puts us in a bad spot
for a little bit of a time here
well and i think that people need to be
smart they need to be vigilant hopefully
people won't panic you don't want the
society to collapse over fear of
something that we just don't know enough
about but uh but from a sports league
standpoint it is something to be
concerned about and i'm already getting
emails from people saying oh the flu
kills thousands every year look the
mortality rate for this thing is
20 times greater than the flu right
you're ex it's 0.1 for the flu right
it's two percent for coronavirus so this
is not it's just the flu the flu kills
people too like that's okay oh what the
hell it kills people yeah we shouldn't
worry about it right maybe we should
anything that kills people we should
worry about on that note have a great
tuesday see you wednesday see ya
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports